I was pretty hesitant to get into rabbits
when I first started home studying.
Chickens just seem like the answer for your meat needs.
While chickens are easy to raise
and small animals
that you can pretty much just raise anywhere in your backyard,
they do take up a considerable amount of room
if you're free ranging them.
They can be loud
and when raising a prolific breed that creates a lot of meat fast.
Unique Cornish cross,
which means you need to rely on a hatchery to hatch your eggs for you.
While you could get into some heritage breeds
and they take a long time to grow out,
rabbits are kind of the answer.
They're fast growing, they multiply,
and you can do this on a small scale.
You don't need a lot of space.
And they taste delicious. They're very mild.
Me they don't taste gamey.
Maybe wild rabbit taste gamey,
but the rabbit raised domestically taste just like chicken.
The flavour is a bit more complex than chicken,
but it's just as tender if cooked correctly.
Today I'm gonna cook a traditional rabbit stew.
All the ingredients, this was what I had on hand.
You can definitely add more spices and different vegetables
like celery, but I just had carrots and onions.
I added Coors butter and some broth I made for my backyard chickens.
This is came out so beautiful.
The house smelled amazing while I was cooking this.
The meat was so tender it Just slid right off the bone.
And it paired amazingly with some sourdough and Coors butter.